[Music]
most def for a second good son
I got this today it got mixed of that
even there to song with Gwen Stefani now
this is rod Simba this is one of the
homies we made it for the show bro that
voice you hear
Martellus Bennett Marty B I would say
during your time in the NFL a top 3
interview and I would say a top 3 human
as well
Oh what thank you yeah I'm me I'm me top
3 I just I don't know how the number 1 I
don't know the other two are like tears
on top - but I'm not - yeah we have a
very special time with Marty because he
is not just a Super Bowl winner he is
now a best-selling author and so is your
brother yeah yeah and I'm curious if
your parents they have - Super Bowl
champions but also - best-selling
authors which one do you think they talk
about more when they see other people
probably pairs on the vibe of the room
oh yeah I think they use it they got
tools like your kid did this Oh am i kid
the day yeah like it's nothing up each
other yes I don't really know I think
they've they think they're pretty proud
of both I think this is amazing the book
is called dear black boy yes and having
read a ton about it and getting my hands
on it now you you've always been someone
that preaches representation and also
that football isn't everything and I'm
gonna give a warning a little bit to the
homies right now we're gonna talk a lot
of not football today because I think
when you when you're with somebody
that's super with it and super
intelligent and aware and is experienced
a lot sometimes I like to talk about
things that are not football I think
it's the best thing to talk about well
what really set it off as I'm reading an
interview that you did and you had a
quote where you said that football was
it's like tiring to you that ever since
you've gotten out of football that you
feel like you've gotten kind of your
life back yeah and what's so interesting
is I talk to so many athletes that they
don't know what to do with their lives
but yours has been this release it must
feel great yeah it's been great I mean
the game of football has always been
interested because it's a weight on your
shoulders it's like this
the stress of like performing each week
performing each game performing each
practice performing in the meetings you
always though you're always interviewing
for the job and your job is never secure
and that's a doing that for entire
lifespan for most of my life it's just
kind of like it's still just as heavy it
was in the beginning as it was in the
end yeah and to move on from it it's
just like whoo like I could just
actually be everything I want to be and
do what I want to do without the
pressures of not only the team but the
the coaches the teammates and things
like that and just put the pressure on
myself to be the human being I want to
be I'm reading one of the blogs you did
on your imagination agency website and
you're talking about being in Japan and
you're talking about these landscape
shrines and quiet solitude and I began
to recognize when peace was present I
began to notice that peace appeared when
I had creative thoughts and ideas
anytime I would think about football
I felt chaos in my spirit and you wrote
this blog during was it your last year
of playing this was this was right
before I retired I went to Japan and
then I came back and retired once I got
back from Japan you something was in
your mind about needing to go to Japan
your amazing wife bought you a ticket
for one for ten days yes Tom Brady
hooked you up with some guide the fact
that Tom Brady is like oh no I got a guy
in Japan Leonard he's amazing like you
need to talk to Brad Brad talk to linear
they may set it up but as soon as I got
there I went to with the dinner and he
kind of like laid out a lot of Japan now
Tom Wyatt came yeah you know I was like
on a spiritual pilgrimage and he was
like oh this is a perfect place at the
way of the conversation and he told him
about the samurais and the tea
ceremonies and how to drink tea with my
elbows and everything's right my first
introduction was in English which was
great because after that it was a much
English yeah but I I think what's so
interesting is whether you're making
things whether you're living your life
trying to find present I think is one of
the hardest things to always stay in and
acknowledging that you're gonna go out
of present you're gonna go to future
you're gonna go to pass but come back to
present mm-hmm but for you to have that
moment has that moment been able to
stick with you and like readjust to you
ever since that trip yeah me I've been
able to remove the ego even more
since I left Japan I think Japan is
really a place where ego is not present
and and to be in a Shinto shrine or to
be and that's um so much beauty you have
to be present otherwise you'll miss out
on how beautiful it is so it's just so
quiet cuz there's hundreds and hundreds
of people walking around but there's no
noises there's no one's talking there's
nothing like you even whisper we have to
say something just out of just just
because it's just so quiet a lot of
servers are loud yeah so it's like I
want to say nothing suey the hero of me
hos my my two guys over there so when
I'm in that shrine and I'm there in
those moments I'm really just taking in
those moments and I'm able to find
president I'm able to be present and and
find peace and the whole thing was like
when I'm talking to him and talk about
like like I left the company happy
samurai and I didn't realize like the
Warriors over there were the most
beautiful people right the samurais are
the reason why they have the Shinto
shrines and the Guardians and they
wanted so but they want to be surrounded
by beauty and as warriors like I feel
myself as in my past life I was a
warrior I too want to be surrounded by
beauty and like how they created beauty
I like to create beauty and the things
that I make too so there was a
connection with the samurai as well with
that type of that type of vibe I know
entire experience was just like it was
just me and my mind in my notebook cuz
there's a ton of friends that what time
differences was so big yeah face time my
wife or whatever like five eight in the
morning although Bill Belichick did call
me one time in like 4 a.m. and while I
was there but are you coming back yeah
so we're way when I think about being
present and then I think about Bill
being like we're on to Cincinnati like
that man is always in the present I
don't know if he's like necessarily
enjoying it like we're all enjoying it
maybe yes maybe like were the I don't
know well I think that it's hard to be
impressive because most people
ego-driven we don't really recognize and
a lot people don't recognize when the
ego is present because we are controlled
by the ego so the only way the ego can
survive is by living in the past or the
future it cannot be in the present
because they only live on things it has
done or things that it thinks it's going
to do next and we're in the present at
you go has not done anything so
therefore you have to be egoless to be
present so most people who live in the
past in the future and most people don't
want to deal with it now right and as
moments where you can feel once you
start to recognize being present you
could recognize
when you in and when you're out so you
could kind of sinner yourself with your
breath yes Angela same thing that's all
that I think you mentioned so many
things there one about you know what
your purpose is and doing something like
the samurai and leaving something and
beautiful people I think that's what
you're trying to do with tear black boy
and I think the other thing you said
just now about ego goes into this tell
me if I'm wrong it seems like you're
tired of young black boys being told you
want to be successful be an athlete yes
I'm pissed off that's me on it I could
tell it's something that you're like I
want to help take the power back
yes this whole thing I want to give the
power back to the youth and let them
know like you know for some of us to
take way too long to discover that if I
discover it now I want to introduce them
to the path to where they could discover
it for themselves so like where we come
from everyone feels like the pinnacle is
the B to top athlete in the world when
everyone pinnacle could be different
like just because you would like comic
books you could be the best comic book
writer in the world you could be the
best art that you could be the best
illustrator let's shoot dude you wrote
in your blog about hero Dreams of Sushi
I mean I recommend that documentary to
everybody I'm watching this dude in a
subway making the most expensive sushi
in the world and he does it every
[ __ ] day and every day he gets a
little bit better and that dude ain't
ballin and that dude lives with his wife
and his kids in the in a little
apartment but he's the most
world-renowned sushi chef I think he's
balling he just doesn't live but I think
he just lived below his means that's my
that's my ego you should be followed
yeah I got tons of money just sitting
somewhere but what does he need it for
yeah cuz there's his life purpose is a
nice pursuit of his dream
yes his dream and I think everyone else
to pursue their dreams the same way we
start kids so young at like running and
running fast sprint you know jump higher
dribble you know shooting form to
prepare to the win at this game whoever
is on a court order feel but we don't
start with that same preparation for
them when their life magic we put so
much into a kid where if you gave him a
camera if you have a kid a camera and
put that same emphasis behind hey this
is a film this is a structure this how
should we all sat around and watched
what he shot that day and celebrated
that like we would a sporting event you
will more kids will be into it yeah what
the kid wants to be celebrated and
rightfully so because who doesn't want
to be celebrated as the key
you want to feel of course you want to
feel like the things you love or value
to the people that you love and you
value in your life so it's like how do
we take the emphasis off of just like
this kid is a photographer and he really
like photography to the whole community
should be behind his photography like
they are about the player who's got the
mean cross yeah it's interesting because
I think one thing you said in an
interview I think you do with Lisa
Mullins you said when you sign your kids
up for peewee football you're signing
over their identity if you're not
playing close attention can I ask a
personal question yeah who when you were
growing up to find your identity and you
looked back and you were like damn I
didn't even know that person would have
the power like it was turned over to
them I never gave it up to anyone
oh really not like that this didn't
happen to you peewee football world cuz
I that what I kind of ran with that was
a coach can define a child it can like I
think and not only the coach but the
cheering of like the idea of the
conditioner from young age become an
athlete you be that's what you become
like you try they try to make you so you
think the same as everyone else and if
you different it's like oh you're
individual like we don't have space
fingers will do it the team do do the
team player a team player but the idea
what a team player is is to slice
through your individual L individualism
which is a major crime like by robbing
people of their individualism we robbed
in the world of awesomeness right if we
get all these people to start thinking
the same so for me I like there was a
time where I was playing on his hoop lit
up three on three tournament and I ain't
like the coach I quit in the middle of
the tournament cuz he trying to make me
be something I wasn't like I didn't same
thing Calvin Murphy was my culture and
basketball when I was a kid - I quit his
team in the mid of the game like nah man
like that's not who I am you know Sam I
always some people say I was a dick or
[ __ ] as a kid like a little [ __ ]
Bennett whatever but it was just cuz I
always felt like they were trying to
like position me put me in like not only
make me make me a better basketball
player right I don't need you to change
the human being that I am what are we
gonna win like ten year old travel like
yeah this is about me learning all ages
yeah even an NFL like coaches like they
feel like every black kid need a father
figure I don't your father figure my dad
is in my life I don't coach me yeah I
don't need a dad I need a coach like
make me a better football player that's
what your job is I don't need you to try
to shake me and mold me into a human
like no football player I separate the
two like your job is to help you become
a great player I'm working on myself as
a person mmm you're you and your brother
I feel like you both have that belief in
you is that does that come from your dad
I I don't know who I mean I don't know
if it come from my dad or my mom I think
it's just something that we kind of
developed through circumstances of the
parenting that we had and my parents
really my desk because my my mom speaks
her mind so I think they just think it's
kind of if I came from a point of view
when I was just kind of like dad dad I'm
[ __ ] with Calvin Murphy you know say
he's like that's what we're doing yeah
yeah you know so not to the way where
there was like you know enabled him but
at the same time it was like they knew
that would go harder wherever I chose to
do like when I was in band or when I was
in whatever it was I was doing at the
time I was just kind of like trying to
be the best
I think what's cool about this too is
you're not just saying you could do
anything with dear black boy I think
you're also saying the pressure is not
on you to be a professional athlete you
don't have to be that yes sometimes we
get told what we should be mm-hmm
especially someone like you I'm sure you
were a big kid yeah and I'm sure people
told you all the time you know you
should go play pro yeah and it becomes a
burden yeah what happens is we start to
dream dreams for kids right and we never
let the kids develop their own dreams
and show us their dreams to us so they
both grew up thinking that their dreams
are something else because we planted
that dream on them instead of letting
them reveal their dreams to us and we
help them fulfill those dreams right so
from a young age if you're a big kid you
fast first question even now if I get an
uber hood what sport do you play you
know saying they don't actually were you
interested in or what do you do what do
you like they actually what sport do you
play and I think that's for me that's
offensive because it's like is that all
you see when you see me right and that's
the problem when they see these black
kids all they see are athletes they
don't see dreamers I don't see riders
they don't see movie directors they
don't see architects and that's what's
the problem is and so when orosi when
you see yourself in the world that's
what you start to believe in as a kid
too so now with the change of reflection
by changing what we could be so that we
could see ourselves and all these
different fields of life and that's what
representation is important
representation I I think a lot of times
people that are very well represented
they have to
listen to hear someone when they're not
often represented to call it out because
you won't realize it yeah for me I'm at
Black Panther with my fiancee and we're
watching the movie and afterwards I'm
ready to break it down like I do every
month like this I like that I would have
done this and she just said she was
already on Fandango buying a ticket for
the next day she's Nigerian yes and I
was like what I was like babe you fall
asleep in every movie like she fell
asleep in infinity war yeah like I had
to wake her I'll be like she was out but
she went Adam I've never seen myself on
camera like that
I've never seen an action star that
looks like me yes and for me I was like
so like we went out and got food and we
just talked about it because I never
thought because I had never realized
that about represent me I have kids
together you know if you're human you
must see the world differently right cuz
you right now as a kid as your parents
as a when you were a kid your parents
never had to worry about taking you to a
movie and making sure that you could see
yourself in a movie like I gonna watch
movies with my daughter just like I hope
there's I hope there's someone in this
movie that looks like her right
I was left cuz like arendelle there's
not one black person with Erindale in
frozen everybody like well you know it's
Norway I was like but it's not a real
place they created it they could have
black people there if they wanted to
there's a complete fictitious like tons
of black people don't Kostas think we
got to be at a black person a movie with
Olaf yeah damn but that's what's a no
well I don't I was gonna give away
endgame but I can't do that but I feel
like there are some characters that are
about to start switching I do I mean I
think I haven't seen in game yet but I
think my theories are gonna come true
yeah but representation I mean so who
did you actually have to look up to when
you were a kid as far as what anything
like who were the ones that stuck out to
you like as you look back now we always
had to be the black version or something
like I wanted to be the black Bruce
Wayne the black black Walt Disney black
whatever I would be the white Ahmad
Rashad I'm not even [ __ ] kidding I
said we had it I like I would like to be
the black Ellen you know I think she
crushes you but at the same time we
always had to put the prefix of black in
front of things to see ourselves in it
like if a kid doesn't have a great
imagination which
I was lucky to be a quick wit I could
see myself in those roles and not really
see that I could be there but most kids
are like oh we can't really we don't
belong there that's not for us that's
for them so I mean we are static shock
you know and yeah I mean I love blade
Skeeter
yeah yes Mike right they want skaters
black there wasn't main characters
though no he was a psycho right wasn't
he blue they never made him bite yeah
they just got a green even piccolo was
green damn we all know Piccolo's black
just yeah attitude jack rot one thing
that I this happens to me all the time
this Gavin to me with a waiter this
could happen to me with a flight
attendant I see what the conflict
they're facing is and I want to help
them and it's like a dichotomy in their
life and I'm fascinated with this
dichotomy in your life you win the Super
Bowl
and you have this quote where I was
extremely happy then I felt what is this
and I felt like I got bamboozled I
wasn't it was until recently I became a
full person what was it like to sit
around or stand around and you see all
these other people with all this joy and
you're really realizing something that I
fear which is reached potential that's
unfulfilled mm-hmm what was it like to
see everyone going ah and in your head
you're going Dan this ain't it yeah I
see we won I was excited because we won
a game like I like to win and the way we
won I was tired and a [ __ ] like
I cry because it was like damn we really
won this [ __ ] and we came back oh just
like a just awesome moment but like when
I started like really think about it
like more guys were like I was trying to
make myself be as joyous as they were
you know saying and reflective looking
at it it was just kind of like well how
am I supposed to feel like my brother
told me it felt like having another
child and everyone else is like the
greatest thing ever you know saying yeah
why not for me but when you talk about
fulfilled potential there's two
different I think that you fulfilling
the potential or someone else placed on
you not the potential of you in your
life no doubt so like for me like if I
score like I look back now to connect
with kids through my books and the
things that I make when a kid screams
like about a chapter they laugh out loud
to me that's way more empowering than
when someone screaming when I caught a
pass in the end zone
like I've never really felt that like I
just like to compete and play yeah
everything else around it didn't really
matter like if I was you know saying I
just want to be the best at what I was
doing but all this other [ __ ] that came
along with I never I never really cared
for wow did you realize that early on
you just you were just like so good at
it well I mean I was number one football
number one basketball player in Texas
but no I mean early on like you play
football your homies play my brother is
my roommate in college like fun to kick
it with it's fun to kick it with it but
once it became a job like I haven't
really no friends from the NFL I played
it in my field for a decade and who are
your best friends in the NFL
probably Ryan Mundy and Brandon Marshall
and your brother I don't count him
though cuz he's been my best friend my
whole life brain there's a lot like you
to Brandon someone I think when his
careers over when he when it's fully
accepted yeah he could do amazing things
I think he would do amazing things we
talk about it all the time but like I
just like I felt like the on the field I
connected with everybody but once the
game was over I didn't connect to anyone
like the locker was one of loneliest
places for me did you ever do arts
locker room yeah I draw all the time
Mike's a drawing I just wasn't sure if
you do in the locker room yeah I do
I do draw all the time I've never been
afraid to be myself out loud I was gonna
say like if I went to like the tight end
room would we have like pictures on
walls yeah when you come to inside a
room like I would meet what caused a bar
like sailing the Patriots and yeah on
Saturday mornings where we go through
whoever I'll just have water colors and
I'll be paying in my notebook man while
he'll be going over to plays and I bet
it helps you retain it more yes and
that's why he didn't really bother dude
I do that - were all like color and I'll
like listen to podcast and I'll get done
like I remembered every year I think
it's something about doodling and making
things he would never like he'd ask me a
question and I first was kind of like he
was kind of like a little iffy about it
but then he told me a question up like
boom boom boom boom this this net and
then I'm an avid note-taker and I don't
make mistakes on the field so it kind of
like whatever the hell he's doing is
working so they just didn't bother me
but do you have other coaches who I
remember yeah was ever at odds with each
other yeah yeah so I was playing for the
Dallas Cowboys and it was installing
plays and they do so they say like
they'll say dagger right and a signal
for dagger be a dagger through a heart
so I wouldn't draw plays I'll just
remember like that's a 94 combination
like
you run a nine Indonesia yes right and
what I would do is I would just draw a
knife through a heart on my paper so
every single play they would call I
would just draw a symbol and they were I
mean with the player so one of the
cultures got my notebook and he was just
kind of like what is this you're not
paying attention it was like my second
year or my rookie year he's like you're
not paying attention you can't get
anything right blah blah blah blah and
then I was like no that's dagger that's
a 94 combination this is that you said
there's a 70 you know say so then he was
like he react well to that well he was
still black oh you still want to be a
dick but didn't know how much dick to be
yeah you realized that your memorization
technique is how the best memory people
in the world remember things I was just
listening to this Adam grant podcast
where if you really want to remember
people's names like if you really want
to my my name was Adam you would find
one aspect of my face and you would
dramatically like use your creativity
like if my eyes like started crying
mm-hmm and like it was just like a
waterfall and you were like Adam so the
next time you saw me you would see that
in your head you back oh that's Adam
look at it it has to be that and that's
what you were doing I always think about
your left eye why I got a weird left eye
so just cuz like oh my god I was like
why is this smaller my right eye what
nobody no two human Buca any human 1/2
that appears to different people there's
not - except for Samuel Jackson I mean
some people say we look alike - I like
Samuel Jackson he's known about being
the most symmetrical face is he in
holidays my favorite actor I got to kick
it with him how was it incredible I did
the match the Tiger Woods Phil Mickelson
thing yeah and it was me Samuel Jackson
and Charles Barkley and this gal fer Pat
Perez and he gets that he was turning to
keel at night in the morning was amazing
yeah and we're just hanging out the
whole time and there was that part where
like you want to be like so Sam yeah and
right when I was gonna do that Tiger
took a shot and he goes god damn it and
he's like look at me goes Adam and I was
like no because they [ __ ] suck
and I was like they do suck saying it
like he's just he's so cool I'm like
Samuel Jackson is our bit like how Bill
Murray is to the community the white
community all these mythological these
myths about him and people
he's met I feel like that's how Sam is
the difference is is that Bill is Sam
ain't doing nothing like Sam's like I
want to be by myself I don't wanna play
golf or absolutely and I don't do
anything Bill Murray's like no I want to
steal french fries at like yeah well Jax
doesn't want to mess with any mother
from now yeah bill murders bill marry
with sense yeah bill marries out there
doing crazy
I know so Sam's your number one if bill
was black he probably arrested already
between me and grot unbelievably dense
the Lombardi Trophy
and we celebrated I know he put his mark
on it what that's crazy this is funny it
is grukk for you Oh classic rock man
grassley Larry you know what I do want
to say I want to say one thing about
your brother okay because in case you
guys didn't know the charges against
your brother were dropped yes boy yeah
sure a lot of people like to talk about
all the charges when they came about
elderly injure Lee injuries to the
elderly heck the Houston Police Chief
came out and said that your brother was
morally bankrupt in March of 2018 but
guess what the chief of staff of the
Harris County District Attorney's Office
recently said we dismissed this case in
the interest of justice after looking at
the evidence it was the right thing to
do we're probably not gonna get an
apology from this Houston police chief
we're probably not gonna get any media
people we're attracting all of their
statements and then talking about
connecting this to other things on the
field and really running with that
morally bankrupt cliff but I just wanted
everyone to know that uh he's good and
that Michael Bennett didn't do anything
and this was all a ruse and if you had
any issue with him then there's an issue
that you have with yourself yeah I think
that I did like black players protested
and a lot of people wanting to be bad
people like they want them to do wrong
they want to be able to say bad things
about them so why anything come on I
told you they stand it's just an
assessee yeah so everyone wants to jump
with a p-value everything else yes
that's exactly what
was which is uh well you know saying the
whole situation is you know being attack
attacking these players for different
things these are players who were who
were built into the communities they're
doing more to half the people even her
brother do that people don't even
realize who I mean I don't wanna make
myself sound like a bad person but [ __ ]
like from before visit talk about he
fights inequality women's rights he does
a lot of stuff for Indian reservations
he does things with food deserts where
they don't have food where they don't
have food he up something build
community gardens and eat how to do
their own food market oh yeah the
farmers market but he also does that
detention centers so he goes to
detention centers and he talks to the
kids and he helps them plant and grow
things he also fights obesity so he
always camps are based around obesity so
he teaches people how to shop for
groceries and how to eat and how to cook
he does also does he build hall he's
working on building a school in Africa
right now Wow
he's also mean the list goes on like he
just does so many a different day and
yet they could call him morally bankrupt
oh yeah he belts people at jail too from
time to time Wow
yeah just he's just a really good human
he fights for rice of everybody and he
does women's marches he donates bikes he
does he's black Santa he donates clothes
like Christmas gifts like he does stuff
still in Seattle yeah everywhere you go
so I mean I think he's a phenomenal
human being I just wanted to give him a
shout out and let you kind of talk about
it just because I saw you you posted on
IG and and kind of like give a message
being like no one's good to say this and
talk about it's gonna get swept under
the round I think that's bad because no
one soon as information comes out
everyone jumps on it but then when the
information is taken away and it's
proven to be wrong no one goes like hey
we issued a article on March 17th I said
this about Michael Bennett those those
have been retracted no one talked about
this as the case has been dropped they
don't go to it that's not all over the
news I might put a little thing right
there but they don't jump on TV and blah
early bankrupt I have always been
someone that thinks if players can be
suspended so can media members they
should be [ __ ] we lying out of
time all the time and the worst thing is
though - as a black player would I say
oh he pushed over an elderly woman it'll
get on TV or black person guilty we'd be
like oh yeah he's morally bankrupt and a
white kid blow some [ __ ] up and they'd
be like oh you know he's a he loves his
family he's a good kid he's just got a
little lost
he's a little stressed out right yeah he
stressed out yeah come on yeah no III
think like when reporters are like this
team is definitely doing this and they
don't you gotta send a week out bro yes
Ari you took a shot they don't take a
shot yeah because there needs to be some
form of growth now this is like you guys
at the year out you mean like if you're
gonna come at somebody and be like this
happened I know who that liked it yes
bro you're out oh come back and be
honest like look I was wrong which is
more powerful yes I was wrong the facts
said this but I did have all the facts
what do we start talking about the
beginning ego yeah ego won't let you do
that no because the nasty [ __ ] feeds the
ego yes cuz the nasty should get you
clicks yeah it's that dopamine yes an
ego loves that dopamine bro yeah ego
those dope for real life people get high
yeah favorites yeah the only other
Seattle thing that I had speaking of
former Seattle is do you like Russell
Wilson right now do I like you that's
his new name Russell Wilson did with his
wife cause him well he's gone through a
transformation man comes out there he
gets the contract hey Seattle we got
ourselves a deal you've seen all this
right I don't really pay attention to
rest of will soon Wow cuz what's
happening right now he's getting his
hair braided on IG I saw that I've
popped the bonus shaver he came out
yeah pods on the same room but no
Russell has been popping up a lot on the
shade room I know they probably paying
him though but then he posts yesterday
or in the of the few days ago in front
of a new G Wagen he goes it's a G thing
with a big ass down jacket well I think
he's probably well he tried to do is
rediscover his blackness that's what it
I can yeah yeah so that happens often I
mean he is the first black quarterback
to ever leave the white
to marry a black woman like they look
happy together look if they're happy I
went back into Getty and I looked up
Russell Wilson from five years ago right
after he won the Super Bowl with his
ex-wife in New York looking crusty as
[ __ ] like he looked he looked like he
was having a miserable time like there's
literally pictures of him in the rain
like walking in the rain being like oh
and then I look at him now and he is
glowing that's good that means he found
the right woman for hounded yeah that's
how important a woman I think it so he
found the right one I think he's found a
woman I think what's happening is he
found someone that's empowered him to be
himself yeah so right now what you see
it is him coming out of his cocoon to
show that he put around himself cause he
felt like he had to be a certain way but
the way that she's loving him she loves
him for who he is it was a shell yeah so
it was a show but now he gets to reveal
himself to the world and I think that's
why he's a bit happier and I think she
empowered that for him and anytime you
have a relationship with someone who
empowers you to be yourself it's a
beautiful thing beautiful thing I think
Russell seems like changing it seems
like he's changed him but he's really
becoming himself yes I was just
comparing it to Steve Urkel or Stephan
that's why I was called yes he's like
what in the time machine and came out
and now he's like this is who I really
do we still say go Hawks at the end of
his always thing yeah but now he goes go
home so you haven't seen now I'm just
gonna play this one thing for you
because it was incredible and as someone
that's so unabashedly themselves that's
why I'm fascinated by it because I could
never imagine being something else I
hear this is what he did
[Music]
yeah H I'm sexy right I don't know that
[ __ ] is this just crazy I didn't see
that Rachelle well yeah I've never seen
that before hey man yo see you but
remember as an athlete there's an
identity crisis right all these athletes
have identity they said there's a form
of PTSD that happens after they play but
it's also for my identity crisis because
you saw your identity over once you
start playing at a young age so now once
you get to older you start to rediscover
yourself you want your identity back so
now you know he feel like he's in a
position where he could probably become
who he always thought he was supposed to
be in the first place instead of who he
thought he was groomed to be how hard is
it to maintain your identity in NFL yeah
it's extremely hard I mean you have to
work at it really yeah it's easy to try
to become because it's easy to try to
become what they want you to be because
they pay you right so most guys want to
get paid I was I was in power because in
my third year I was gonna retired and I
realized I didn't need the NFL you know
since you were able to say no you were
said others I don't need yeah I was
about to retire I was just like man [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I'm going you know I'm saying
and that moment from then I was realized
that yeah whenever I'm out I'm out you
know I'm saying it from then on I was
just like I'm gonna be Who I am they
better set me for who I am I'm gonna do
it I come on always been a good teammate
as far as playing coming to practice and
perform yeah like but I'm gonna be
Martellus right I'm not gonna be who
they want me be I ain't gonna be you
know I don't have a rush sale but you
know saying wherever that might be I was
gonna be that was just gonna be myself
and I tell and it proved because
beginning of my career everybody's like
oh this guy's distracted he has too many
interests is blah blah blah blah didn't
my career it's like oh this guy's so
well-rounded he's a genius he's really
smart and it's like I really didn't
really change up I was still diving into
all the things that I love
it was frowned upon when I was rapping
and I was ya doing songs and art shows
and stuff when I play it as a rookie and
then as I got older it was what was
celebrated most about me as a player and
I'll be remembered for the person I was
moreso than the player I was on the
field and to me that's more empowering
than someone to be like more people have
stories about me as a person than I do
as a player they don't mean I didn't
make a lot of big players I got game
winners I made big clutch catches but
people remember the person I am that's
got to feel good yeah because I'm gonna
be the same person forever but I'm not
gonna be the same player forever do you
think you would ever speak to other NFL
players yeah they pay me yeah they got
money they do it but do players reach
out to you though yeah I'm the guy to
call when you get ready to go in
retirement now because every guy's like
you're doing it right so I get phone
calls of all guys trying to transition
and how to transition but my whole
there's their fear in their voice
there's always fear because one they
haven't built the British at the cross
so now you're doing that early on I
built the bridge when everybody else was
like oh he why is he going to
Nickelodeon or why is he meeting with
people at Disney or why he's doing this
everybody do an internship right yeah
why are you interning when you make
millions we got working out right now
yeah I miss a little thing I told guys
like I work out and then I go to my
internships and I learned and I learned
yeah but you guys work out you go party
mess with women and and play video games
right like I'm with the people who built
the video games you play mm-hmm so
that's a whole different philosophy a
lot of times well guys [ __ ] up with two
is that they don't put himself in
position to see like if guys are
interested in politics they'll go to the
inaugural the presidential ball or any
of that stuff or anything like that
they'll be at the BT Awards but being at
the BT wars you're not gonna be anyone
else that you need to meet to Susilo to
succeed in life it's about being in the
right domain so if I have this domain I
would introduce myself to and this is
the practice I want to dive into I need
to surround myself or be in a room with
those people who are in those domains
sure otherwise I could never make the
introduction into that space so most
guys they just do what's cool and not
what they want what's cool to them Yeah
right there rather be seen and then
instead of being behind scenes you know
I'm saying so how's your mentor I don't
have a mentor you just kind of figure
this all out yourself there's to me all
the books I read I look for mentors
several different times I like at meal
to be my mentor from Pixar I've talked
to people from Nickelodeon I've talked
to several different people to mentor me
but no one really I'm gonna be honest
it's probably good that you don't have a
mentor yeah you're just gonna adapt some
of their style and your two individuals
for that and that's the whole thing like
I [ __ ] up all the time like I mess up
all the time but I'm figuring it out
mistakes are the best I know there's not
saying like I have so many lessons
Noelle's just lessons yeah and the way
that I've been working in the way that
I've been learning is all about
self-discovery it's like only
discovering myself but also discovering
the way things work like I may make a
book or I may do a practice and the
books not bad but the way I rolled it
out man and not being a right strategic
plan or the way I printed it where I
printed it humming copies I print it so
it's like constantly growing my company
and growing myself as a business leader
and as a writer and a creator so it's
like I'm learning like I Reese crips I
researched I mean there's movies out
like I'll dive into the scripts of all
these movies reading them learning how
they did things that a structure sure
and I break that apart things I don't
like things I do like I'll take like
I'll go watch like all Tim Burton's
interviews and see what he's talking
about my favorite movies that he made
and what made him do certain things it's
just about just without a mentor is you
have to find the information for
yourself but having a mentor is pretty
much being lazy for the most part and I
mean it's cooled it I guess it's cool to
have a mentor but I think it's less cool
to say at a dinner party yes I have he's
my mentor but I have thousands of
mentors and all the books that I have in
all the books I read I will say I have a
lot of people that that go into my DMS
they say I would love to work under you
I'd like to learn from you and I really
wanted to say to all of them all you
have to do is watch my [ __ ] yeah
everything that people do they put out
there and you can get free mentorship
all the time especially with social
media now if they're tweeting or they're
facebooking or they're instagramming or
you see their work or it's explained
that like there's free lessons all over
the place yeah but we live in a display
culture now everybody want to beast
everybody wants to be seen but they
don't want to be seen doing the work you
know saying like being seen next to you
makes them as value to them right just
researching you from a distance it
doesn't identify they had a value dog
they can't go be like oh yeah I've been
researching left Cole for the last four
months or whatever this is well you're
kind of crazy for doing that but you
shouldn't said it kind of crazy yeah you
should play there's something about this
guy that I like that he does first
that's the hardest thing for me and
Charlamagne for like three months one
time did you because I was fascinated at
how he reached a point where people
would sit down the chair and they were
willing to be attacked they were willing
to not know what the [ __ ] was going to
and got excited by it yes and so I read
all those books and I watched all of
this stuff and then I was like who you
know who else I like Andy Cohen yes I'll
watch what happens live because he has
this air of like no one knows so I
watched him and I studied him and I
realized oh he would say you know
Martellus Twitter saying that you
actually used to date Madonna yeah I'd
be like Twitter didn't say [ __ ] the show
just started
yeah how do you have a card with a tweet
on it yeah no that's what you want so I
just you know Ellen how does she dancing
yes she uses on to disarm people and so
I would study all these people and I'm
not where I want to be yeah in the
finished product that's great though you
have to kind of pick apart from every
but that is great that you know that
you're not where you want to be because
you know where you want to go hundred
most people don't know where they want
to go they just don't want to be where
they head but the what's my retort to
that would go I don't know where I want
to go cuz I don't think I've seen it yet
because it's in here do what you were
saying about like you're just kind of
unraveling yourself mm-hmm we all we all
like have goals that we want to achieve
but I think we can all achieve bigger
than what we even think I don't think
that we dream big enough because I think
that I think a lot of people are afraid
to being successful like they say they
want to be successful but what would
comes with success me there's
accountability responsibility and you
have to be consistent
how many dumb [ __ ] go I don't
know if I want to win the lottery man
let the taxes and [ __ ] what one stop
thinking about the lot like I have a
frog brothers that plays a lot oh my
friend he goes honestly I talk about the
lottery so much that I gotta win the
lottery that's not how it works yeah put
it to the you know how it works but but
people yeah oh you're right they're
afraid of success but the lottery is
self to be jay-z all those cameramen but
the lottery itself the latter is self is
a big sign of how the community is right
people would really risk or pay play
like they know the possibility of
winning is very slim but they rather use
their money over and over over again in
hopes of winning it but they're saying
kind of dedication of driving themselves
to become a winner they wouldn't do the
same but if it could be given to me for
a small just
all amount of anything why Joe has to be
that invested in what I'm trying to do
but could win big I think that's how the
majority of the world works yeah
how do you battle that better would like
how do you I think that I'm not I'm not
a money driven person I'm a goal I'm a
Purpose Driven purpose a person so if
you like a 1-week planner one month a
year how much how organized are you I'm
about ten years ahead of myself at most
times but my biggest issues operation I
operate day-to-day although my thoughts
my thoughts are projector more so what's
gonna happen way ahead of time right
right so the way that I operate
sometimes I can't keep up with myself
because I have my day-to-day stuff
that's what I'm doing but also have
these forecasts to what it needs to be
and where it needs to go
just so you're that lighthouse pointing
you in the right direction yeah I
constantly see what I can't what I can
be and what I could become but I don't
really like long-term goes too much
because I realized yeah I'm evolving I'm
changing too and there's so much I don't
know that when I learn it it changes
everything right it's like damn if that
one piece of information but I scrapped
all this [ __ ] I'm stupid being able to
do that yeah so that's kind of how I am
like I kind of constantly like I'm never
not trying to learn like I'm always
trying to study and I was trying to be
better because the letters not people to
depending on me not just in the company
not just my family but the community
like I can't really feel that what I'm
trying to do because then I felt a
community because there's so many black
kids that come up there I'm telling they
don't have to be athletes they have to
show them what success looks like
outside of the field right for me it was
shack rice shackles my favorite athlete
like he did movies he did music he he
had 24-hour fitness gyms Nick alone he
was on Nickelodeon he did everything so
like I went I saw Shaq I thought that's
why I thought athlete was right I didn't
think I fleet was Kobe Bryant right
because Kobe was just really good at
what he did and on the court or whatever
I always put Shaq as the best athlete of
all time because no one did it like Shaq
even to this day Shaq is still the most
dominant personality in basketball have
you ever met him I've met him I when I
was in high school I went out with him
one night when I was an NBA Draft I went
I went in one night
Wow he had his big ass bracelet is gonna
be I'm gonna be hanging with on tomorrow
how are you
once a week for like the last few months
bleach reports owned by Turner I go down
to Turner I do this MBA Twitter show
and it's right there in the insert
inside the NBA and like last week I was
there and Shaq's like DJ oh wow like
pass he's got some guy there with like a
ponytail and he was like he's like man
you can work for me
he was like all I get is nerdy what guys
to make music play that beat and the guy
like hit a beat and he was like instance
and he's just dancing like every time he
walks in he's he's very interesting I
feel like he's an introvert that is such
a personality but he uses that I think
sometimes to deflect people the same
players where I feel like he walks in
and he'll just kind of go and stand
there and everybody will just go hey
Shaq and he'll go mmm and then walk in
but then he'll come out with a
completely different energy yeah that's
how I'm doing I'm an introvert extrovert
but he can read people so well too I
think I can't do I think I could buy biz
the vibration the thing about you have
to come down I want to make Kazaam to
star you boy I want to come back as his
son you know can I be the creepy guy in
the limo that eats like goat eyes yeah
that's the only scene I remember yeah it
just makes me think of my mom's joke my
mom has a joke all the time when she's
just like oh you don't eat meat I could
lamb from the Greek My Big Fat Greek
Wedding that's awesome every time what
the hell are you talking about mom she's
just quoting this one I was like my
quote Friday next Friday I see Michael
you get one house yeah move out the
neighborhood now you're quoting to My
Big Fat Greek Wedding like who are you
now you guys get her a house and all
that yeah she got a house does that feel
good
good night I mean I guess so
cuz I've actually heard I heard Chris
Carter on his show today go oh no my
mom's doing fine and then I heard LeBron
on the shop being like oh my mom's got a
house and she's asking for more and this
is a dynamic that I've never even
thought of you know I just I just don't
feel like it's not about my parents just
about anybody around me every X for
anything I feel like I like just because
I'm driving the Benz I mean you should
be driving at best like sticking out tax
bracket I'm gonna Titans record for a
reason do you say that yeah
that's my biggest issue in life bro that
I wish I could steal from you if I could
like like Space Jam you he's just
[ __ ] telling people right to their
face oh yeah I tell him straight up like
I tell them like and then at first I
used to be kind of cool about it like
well if I give you this money then
you're taking food out my daughter's
mouth and that's a college fund that
you're taken out of but then I was like
oh still be like yeah but it's a c-class
yeah so but for me I just feel like like
a lot of kids the car community when
they make it for like they owe the
community something I don't feel like we
owe anybody anything like my daughter if
my daughter grows up to be the number
one film director in the world and she's
she's the next Bob Iger you know Sam I'm
running to imagination agency though
she's my bob iger yeah she doesn't like
you know me like she gonna start our own
company I don't none of that belongs to
me that's hers less that's all hers now
she want to do something for the family
because it's not a kindness of her heart
thing yeah but you don't have ownership
of my of my success I feel like that's
an issue that you with like dear black
boy is projecting that and part of the
reason I think we project professional
athletics on kids is well then when they
hit it big they're gonna take care of us
yeah and it seems like the easiest route
because we see it it seems attainable
like the tell your kid could be a doctor
doesn't really seem attainable to people
to community but there's so many people
who should have share stories with us
that's on television playing sports we
see guys getting drafted their family
just like ours they come from the same
neighborhood we come from there the same
circumstances we had I'm not a
millionaires like that's the way out
like and we have access to that now like
no one sex about the excess to will have
access to to to other things so I was
like how do we have give kids access or
opportunities to go down these different
fields and these different crafts as
you've gone around on this book tour to
your black boy and you've met a lot of
kids and you've talked to a lot of
parents have you learned anything just
from those interactions yeah I've
learned a lot parents there's a lot
there's a lot of thirst in our community
from the black male I think a lot I felt
like what I learned is about black men
most black men put down their passions
and their dreams to find something to
provide right so a lot of black men
don't follow their dreams the ones that
did follow their dreams are usually the
athletes right there's not tons of them
they follow their dreams they try to
find a job to that does not have doesn't
have to be fulfilling a job has to get
the job done to make
but I think there's this shift this
paradigm shift that's happening that
where black men want their kids that
have a different journey they want them
to know about everything that they're I
think we're on the verge of a black
Renaissance at this moment where the
midst of it yeah like it's really
happened so there's gonna be a lot of
young black craters there changing the
way to pave in a way but also you're
gonna have ownership in the things that
they make because ownership is the most
important thing we have been creating
for so long but we can't really build
because we don't have ownership of it
someone else is making the majority of
the money we're just getting a piece of
it there was one point in time where and
st. Louis there was like 90 black
businesses there used to be at a bank a
freedman bank and all of them used to
put their money over there but then the
guy that was running the bank this is
back in the day where the god I was
running the bank he decided to start
moving their money and then he lost all
the black she was money so they crumbled
a thing in there white people were upset
because these black businesses had
grocery stores and they felt like they
were competing with the other grocery
stores so they came and burnt down the
whole town so you think about those like
a couple of million dollars in a bank of
black ownership so he trying to rebuild
from that they didn't really have the
infrastructure to do that so like that's
a bit moments worse off decades it's
been but it's the same thing still going
on like we've been fighting for
ownership first again at a time which is
ridiculous so now I think guys are
starting to date there's so much more
information out there because the
biggest thing is that we were deprived
of information right we didn't have
access to as much information now all
their change comes from information yes
I just thinking like the King James
Bible you're only the printing press
like the ability for like people to
actually know what they were learning
about and not just trusting somebody
once you get the information in your
hands that's when change can happen yes
so now is about providing information to
these kids that they don't have to be
athletes right they don't have to do
this they'll have to go buy this right
you can't play sports but if you decide
to play sports don't you'll have to
think about it using it to get to the
league you could think about using it to
get you anywhere else you want to get in
life as well so that's the information
I'm delivering like you know when you
think about you the information is the
source and there's a lot information
that we just did not have and and
there's well information she can't see
possibilities because you don't know it
imagine agent imagination agency the
black dear black boy what
I know you're probably working on like a
million other things - yeah dude I've
got a couple of things I'm working on
anything that you can share excited
about yes coming up I decided about I'm
gonna New Mexico soon which I'm excited
about that but there's you got the right
shirt on but I think my legs I got I
have several books I've already finished
I got a new graphic novel I'm working on
I'm starting to do more stuff for adults
what's your writing setup where do you
write everywhere
I have notebooks on me I write the world
is mine and so you do it by a pen paper
like I don't blame notebook paper and
what's your favorite kind of pen is
everybody RSVP fine point oh that's my
favorite pen doesn't smudge too much
none I like him a little juicy I like a
little right we're super thin line I
like it when I make noise either so yeah
I like I like those but I usually
collect places collect people collect
names everywhere I go when I travel or
doing things or conversations like you
may say something I'd like oh they'll be
tight if my character said this in this
moment yeah I tried correct collect
things all over and so I have a notebook
that I carry with me all the time but
then when I write I'm usually in my
studio and write a lot of stuff I write
at home - I like to write in my theater
in my house like I like so quiet it's
quiet and I get to watch movies while
I'm writing and things like that so
that's like one of my favorite places
the right is in it theater and other
Dannette like I don't really like white
right in hotels or things like that
usually my travel is just you know is
usually make your notes and click things
like collect the information I like to
go see things or tell me wake up I mean
usually about 6:30 6:45 most days and do
you get right out of bed yeah I'm not a
bad person on the worst I know my wife
likes to snuggle on something like maybe
we could snuggle on a couch like I don't
care if we snuggle on the couch but I
just don't want to be in the bed like I
should have been here three hours ago
but she we got it got a cuddle yeah well
is cuddle a manatee even the cuddles are
like the cuddles comfortable I like to
be I like to be both parts I like to be
the Spooner and the one that's getting
spoon like sometimes just hold me baby I
will say more the percentage as the
Spooner yeah yeah I agree with that but
I think we both acknowledge when we both
were all over we go
okay we gonna do it for a little bit
yeah you got like that minute or two
when you go okay enough I don't cuddle
me baby girl baby I've had my moments my
I just want to be held near hugged you
know like that's amazing it's pretty
good you think bell chicks a big spoon
do you think he cuddles I think he does
kind of leave me somebody to cuddle with
he's got he's got somebody I know I love
her too she's a bit yeah she yeah she's
so awesome she's so nice to me
we followed shadow Instagram that's
awesome yeah all right so check out the
imagination agency if you have a young
kid if you have no kids
check out dear black boys this your
first like where are you in terms of
books that you've put out this is my
third one what were the one - hey J
Saturday I just heard that from online
yeah hey AJ's bad time I didn't I did a
comic book called cowboy mmm mother's
little kid who tried to make the
football team but he's not good enough
but this time you said I'm not I'm not
pulling any punches I'm going right to
the heart of the matter
yes this was a this was the build a
bridge because what I really wanted
master is my normal writing style is
literary nonsense which would be like
Lewis Carroll's the most famous person
for it so this for me is about building
a bridge to teach kids that they care
they do deserve to experience escapism
and I write escapism like normally like
this was very hard for me to write
because it's just because the messaging
I like to bill wacky worlds
where'd you write this one in my garage
watching the author sterling thing on my
oh I wrote that when I was like that day
that that happened and you wrote all
this one day yeah so you saw that it
impacted you to the point you said [ __ ]
this I'm letting it pour out yeah and
that's why I can't create that moment to
write those the type of literature off
that you know sans no I mean there's a
bunch of inspiration out there actually
because the world's [ __ ] up like this
yeah yeah it's that weird split where
you're like it can create beautiful art
but do I want to I don't want to keep
experiencing them yes exactly
yeah yeah did it feel cathartic
afterwards like no Jimmy's like was like
did you feel better afterwards no no no
is it weird to talk about it then no I
mean at first well first I go to
toriel was weird I was like even with
the book I didn't really like the book
at first because of where it came from
right right and I just it was kind of
dark for me like even though it was like
the I was my least favorite thing I had
made sure and the more I started sharing
it with the world and the more I start
connecting with kids I realized it was a
beautiful thing that came out of the
darkness embrace the pain yeah only good
[ __ ] comes from that [ __ ] like in terms
of growth
yes gross change happens that well I
believe that change happens that one
single moment of time I don't believe
that people change over extended period
times it's just like no they get it and
there's change as much yes
so yeah the one to change to but like
with this with this book I think that
the most beautiful thing about it is
that a lot of other people who were
wanted this message as well right which
I was writing for myself and a young the
young Martellus right when I thought it
was hard to stop myself
I don't saw my brother also saw my
cousins and my friends and and then that
I saw but what I saw is not what the
police are right I saw you know I'm
saying so then that's when I started
thinking about how do we see ourselves
and how does the world see us there's
two different things right they see the
bike boy they see the black boys a
danger but the black boys in danger is
two different things I think it's
interesting they're like you took that
about being in danger and saying like
fighting for your identity but this also
feels like a goodbye letter
to like football Martellus it was if you
see this guy in the front on the first
page he's got this little kid reaching
for his shoes that's me
the idea is like when you retire you see
mark shot those shoes on the telephone
why yes like that I retired from the
game of sports but I had the game I to
get in was a totally different games had
to go back and get my shoes down so that
I could run in his new race and his
marathon the game of life is the one I
really need to win it hmm so yeah you're
in a good spot yeah yeah it's and I'm
sure that there's a part as athletes
reach out to you and they want advice
the journey that you're like I remember
actually I don't know if you've ever
been in that spot well I mean I think
when guys reached out to me the biggest
thing is they when they see me they know
that they can like the fact that like I
smoked we the fact that I work with kids
hey I'm doing something I love I get to
go and margarita dates with my wife on a
regular day during the week most of you
guys can't get to do that because I got
a beat they don't pick the kids up from
school you know say like I'd love the
days I go get picking my daughter from
school and I just take her to a studio
good ice cream and things like that cuz
usually where I work still like so like
those are the best parts of life where I
get the experience why just tell my wife
like baby let's go have lunch real quick
you never get leave for 10 years right
when I'm playing football we could never
leave to go have lunch
most people regular jobs you can go have
lunch with your wife a lot of people
though one don't maybe not want to go
and get lunch from their way yeah that's
why that's the other underlying [ __ ]
that people don't want to say a lot of
you don't we retire because they don't
like their wife or they like their work
they like their work family yeah like to
get away it had the phone dad the phone
in the locker is not for their family
that has here's the address with their
yeah I've seen a lot of that too yeah I
don't want to get anybody else in
trouble I'm sorry you're they I
appreciate you again checking stuff out
and then Twitter your what at Marty
Soares Rick's I like dinosaurs just a
little bit yeah well groove out too nice
sound of rod Simba or Telus Bennett
always the man chicken [ __ ] out tuck you
later huh Marty you're left Co but Marty
just left oh no elbow jump shot say I'm
too hot I'm on the block I'm rapping
like I'm D block where DJ the kids don't
miss take no [ __ ] diamond so yellow look
like my ears just pissed
[Music]